out of the sea
wish I could be
[Music]
well congratulations on the Little
Mermaid thank you very much thank you so
much I really wanted to tell you I saw
it a couple nights ago and twice in the
middle of the movie people erupted into
Applause wow
after Part of Your World sequence and
scuttlebutt brought the house
I love it that's fantastic I feel like
you can like feel lin-manuel Miranda's
fingerprints 100 that's 100 we always
know when we're writing when we write
the the even the outline yeah yeah we
knew exactly where the new song should
should yeah it was exciting because we
had Aquafina and we thought and David
and we thought well let's find something
here and we replaced a full scene there
you know and John you came up with the
title Scott
because it was because it's about the
gossip of what's around the town and be
like there wow the scuttlebutt their
character is so powder oriented yeah
yeah so it was just yeah it's like
nonsense like what she talks is like
nonsensical and that was all written
into the into the piece by Lynn and of
course Alan's beautiful music yes so
good
um and so Rob like this is not your
first IMAX release uh you uh released
Mary Poppins returns yeah we were proud
of that
um on Pirates of the Caribbean yes yes
from stranger Tides yes how do you like
seeing those scenes on an iMac screen
inform how you were going to approach
shooting The Little Mermaid well what I
was I mean listen you learn so much when
you're working on that forum and um and
of course what's so great is that you
get to see sort of much more you know
there's a much Fuller experience you
know you get you the frame frame line
changes so you have all of that I mean
of course there's times when you're
actually having to actually negotiate
when those frame lines change but you
know this was an opportunity which is so
thrilling to experience more water I
mean in more depth and and that's that
is so immersive I mean that's what we
love about IMAX and IMAX 3D it's sort of
like you get to sort of live inside the
world and by and for me you know this I
personally and I I think people will
want to escape into this a magical world
um and and live inside the space with
with with with Ariel and and and and and
and the underwater space even in the
scary spaces you know even when you're
going into Ursula's Lair you know you
get more of it so it's it's I mean it's
it's a plus I mean for me it's always a
plus it's like an enhanced experience
yeah you shot a lot of the film in
imax's expanded one I know aspect ratio
so how did you approach which scenes you
wanted to like expand into and why was
it important important for you to do
that in this movie well you know what it
was actually it was it made it was very
clear you know what I mean you you know
when you're in a vast space
um that you can actually take in more
and of course in all in the entire
underwater space you know that's that's
where you can actually have more
um you know when you're playing an
intimate scene it's not necessary to
sort of expand into a into and you so
you can actually keep keep the form that
you had but there's this is an Epic film
you know and there was a lot of
opportunity to give us more
um and uh that's why you know we that's
why we love working on IMAX um you know
the arm in the IMAX Forum it's really
thrilling awesome and then like so as
you probably know IMAX has a bespoke
theatrical audio mix yes it's released
yes which is fantastic and sound is just
so important oh my goodness it's the
same immersive experience and you're
feeling like wow we're inside the space
it all goes together
um I think we're that's what's so great
about what the ground you know the
groundbreaking you know techniques that
are happening in IMAX because you get a
chance to be immersed in a way in a film
that you never would be if it's sort of
like distant enough uh somehow you're
it's all around you and you're
absolutely right it's all about sound
and visuals I mean I think a lot of
people listen in today's world want to
escape yeah I want to go into a
different world and this is certainly a
place where you can in this kind of in
this kind of film in this story is there
a moment in the movie where you feel
sound is especially important for fan
six it's at IMAX I mean I know if you
haven't I mean for me it's it's the
Shipwreck because
um that is so
um I don't know exciting but also
terrifying and thrilling I mean you know
that you you feel I mean I'm always when
I'm hearing it in an advanced way it is
it is it is astonishing to be to do like
the storm yeah and also the under the
sea and Under the Sea because the
musical acts aspect yes as well as all
the yeah it is I mean that's what's
wonderful when you have uh you know you
have atmosphere but you also have Music
and Sound to help create a production
number like that you know that's really
exciting
um and and I think the final battle is
pretty specifically tacular you know
what I mean you have those tentacles
flying all over the place of the storm
that she's created you know the water
that's flying around you know it the
lightning strikes and all that it's like
it it it's you know it's dramatic and um
you know I want people to be taken it's
you know on this journey with air Ariel
in a deep deep way and so any any way
you can experience that any kind of oral
way or visual way that you can
experience that is is thrilling you know
I want you know it's a reason to get out
of your house and not just sit there
with the remote and experiencing
something with other people in a way
that you could never any anywhere else
it makes it more of an event yes and I
have my last question now it's a fun
question but I'm not gonna lie it's a
really hard question do you have a
favorite Disney song
you can you can pick the one today
because it's hard to pick a forever
forever favorite well I'm gonna pick
mine now
um
because it's from this movie
um it's part of your world yes because
part of your world
it reminds me of Somewhere Over the
Rainbow which is so iconic because when
people refer to the I want song in
musicals they always refer to Part of
Your World because it is the motor of
this film it's it in one musical number
with which has such passion and such
depth it actually moves me so deeply and
and and and lets me understand what this
story is about I'm I I know if you feel
it when I watch the movie when I get
there I'm like I'm so happy because I
know people now it all it all funnels
into one thought
so it does so many things it's beautiful
to hear and Hallie does it so
brilliantly but it's very I don't know
it's it's the Cornerstone of the movie
well I'll just juxtapose you're a
beautiful heart with something small
because it's when I fell in love with
his movies and it's and it's I feel bad
because we did Mary Poppa's returns and
it's from the Mary Poppins back in 64.
but you know the young kid in me came
alive when I heard that score and
supercalifragilistic was just it just
opened up something so joyful and so
there was there were no limits when I
heard that so that I think Walt created
that for me and that's you can still say
it backwards again
come on John yeah let's hear it
fragile Cali lupus say okay
wow I couldn't do that I can't do that
well thank you both thanks for your time
and talking to us about why fans should
experience a little mermaid in IMAX yes
thank you really exciting yes it's
definitely worth it thank you